[Music]
over the years
people who like my work bring up brene
brown's name
more than anyone else and brene told me
that the people who like her work bring
up my name
more than anyone else it turns out that
we may be two sides of the same coin
that our work together is something
bigger than by itself
so what a treat for me to sit down and
talk to brene
and what might surprise people is we
actually don't agree on everything
in fact we even disagree on my own work
[Music]
but one thing is true we respect each
other and we learn from each other
this is a bit of optimism
first and foremost how are you we're
good texas in general is really still
suffering
deaths and just hard stuff i mean it's
insane to me
the pandemic texas you know one of the
whole things that this thing's revealed
to me is just
especially in the united states we think
we're like so far ahead and we got
everything sorted out
and like this whole thing is so faustian
to me like we made a deal to be rich
and we're crap now it is a complete
faustian bargain i mean there's a couple
of bad things first of all
i don't understand why 500 000 people
dead
we are the center of oil and gas
business in the united states
and we've got people dead from a snow
and ice storm
and just the failures in leadership
but no one remembers that when it's time
to vote
we have a leadership vacuum in the
united states i mean we have a
leadership vacuum in the world but it's
really significant in the united states
it's not a recent thing this is a slow
boiling frog and
you can trace it very easily back to the
fall of the berlin wall
where we had this existential threat
outside of our own borders
it was a philosophical and ideological
contest and it doesn't matter what
somebody's politics are you can go back
and listen to jfk
or ronald reagan's inaugural address
they both talked about
peace on earth world peace as driving
ambitions
to say those words right now world peace
it actually sounds cheesy oh yeah and
this idea of like
big purpose and idealism to drive
decisions
was a real thing and made easier by the
fact that there was this
existential threat this contest and when
the soviet union
ran out of money to play in the game we
falsely believed we had won because you
don't win in an infinite game the player
just dropped out it's like
circuit city went bankrupt best buy
didn't win anything and then you start
to see the fact that we no longer
have great purpose we no longer have an
external existential threat
what starts to happen is we become more
and more finite
more and more short-term focused more
and more insular and
the great philosophical contests are no
longer external they become internal so
we no longer perceive external threats
as existential
we now perceive each other as
existential threats we have
opposing political parties that are just
different philosophies of how to advance
what was laid down for us in the
declaration of penance that's all it is
like we think we should go this way well
we think we should go this way
that's what political parties are but
now we actually accuse each other being
anti-american unpatriotic
traitors and view each other as the
threat to america
what i know
i was listening to john meacham has a
podcast series
about great speeches given over time and
i was listening to
kennedy during bay of pigs martin luther
king churchill during
the blitzkrieg and there's a couple
things that struck me one
the big audacious goal that's slightly
out of reach you know the just cause
as you would say and the honesty
and no [ __ ] way they taught i mean
let me tell you
i was listening to this series of
speeches during the bay of pigs where
kennedy was on like
well it seems dire and we're not sure
what we're gonna do
but it does seem really dangerous i'll
get back with y'all tomorrow after we do
some more thinking
our churchill saying we cannot concede
your sons your brothers your fathers
will die but we cannot give up
can you imagine that kind of candid
response
from a politician today that the game is
so finite it actually starts two years
after they're elected because they have
to start campaigning again
yeah i don't think people realize how
powerful being honest really is
it's the whole debate about taking
pilots out of a cockpit can you imagine
getting on a plane with no pilots
where just computers control the
aircraft
and the strong argument could be made
that the computers are way more
reliable yeah less fallible less
fallible than than pilots
but we would rather have a human being
in charge knowing that they make
mistakes because most airplane crashers
are pilot error and it's the same here i
don't think politicians
and leaders recognize that simply being
honest even if i'm gonna make a mistake
is actually way more confident building
than pretending you've got everything
under control when do you think that
shifted
well like i said i think it's been a
steady drum beat since the fall of the
berlin wall
and you can see it it's got nothing to
do with the political parties
you know bush 41 and then clinton and
you start to see especially under the
clinton years
we did a lot of dismantling of
regulation that made us way more
finite minded and by the time you get to
the trump administration trump is not a
cause he's a symptom
for sure and he's the most exaggerated
finite player because that's the path
we've been on
it's really interesting a couple of
thoughts one when trump was elected
i was writing the forward for a book and
they said can you write about your
thoughts and i said you know i think
this is white male power
over making the last stand i think it
could have been trump or anyone else i
think this is someone with a very
specific point of view about
power being finite and using power over
not power with power to and power is
infinite shared
and this is going to be a last stand and
it's probably going to get violent and
crazy
and i think that that happened i think
that this idea of power over versus
power within two
really coincides with what you're
talking about around the fall of the
berlin wall
i'm very uncomfortable and i've thought
about this a lot over the years
and it really bugs me i'm very
uncomfortable with the fact that you
have to have a not that
like it's wonderful and beautiful and
ideological to know what we stand for
but i recognize that that's ethereal
right vision is an ethereal thing
inherently it's intangible
whereas when there's an existential
threat or something or someone who
stands
for something different or opposed to
what you stand for
it's tangible and easier to see and the
challenge i have is do you have to have
a not that
like you know we can all agree in not
that like we don't want to be the soviet
union
do you have to have and i even don't
like the term an enemy
to be clear on what you stand for and
i uncomfortably keep coming to the
answer yes well i'll tell you how this
relates very much to my research
when i asked people about love they told
me about heartbreak when i asked them
about trust they told me about betrayal
when i asked them about connection they
told me about disconnection
so part of the problem is that we lack
actually the language and vocabulary
to talk about what is
people have a really hard time defining
love but they can tell you with
excruciating detail about heartbreak
and if you look into the literature in
psychology and social science across the
board
you'll see that we have 100x the
research on negative emotion than we do
on positive emotion so i think
it's the inability to articulate
in a meaningful galvanizing keyword
being galvanizing
way what is possible what is it about
positive emotion that feels
intangible where negative emotion feels
very real well i think it goes down to
neurobiology i think it goes down to our
wiring
that we are wired for survival
above all else there's not even a close
second in terms of what the brain is
wired to do
and so the brain's interest in positive
affect is not as great as the brain's
acute feelers out for
negative affect everything from fear
and physical threat to emotional threat
to stress
overwhelm anxiety despair
anguish it's how we're wired this
explains a lot but it's also a little
bit depressing
because if it's a biological thing that
means
positive is always intangible and hard
to grasp
and negative is always tangible and easy
to grasp does that mean
you have to have evil to know what good
feels like no
no i mean i'm hardwired most of us are
that if someone
says something really shitty to me or
not one of my children i'm hardwired to
punch him in the face
but i don't do that and so i think we
can
address the hardwiring with mindfulness
and critical thinking but i will tell
you
positive emotion requires more complex
thinking
it requires reality checking some of the
emotional feelings that we're having
i can scare you into joining me
i have to engage with you cognitively
in a thinking way to inspire you to join
me
i don't know i agree that it requires
more thought
for the affirmative but i mean let's
look at your career and my career
right the things that we have come up
with we're not the first people to come
up with for sure people have been
talking about purpose for
thousands of years you and i
learned how to communicate the things we
believe in
the positive by telling good stories
storytelling and storytelling makes
those intangible things feel
tangible and people join
the story and we don't have to be
rational or convince someone to join we
can inspire someone to join because we
can paint a picture of a future
that is so clear to them in their own
imaginations
that they're inspired to say i'd like to
be a part of that please
i disagree go on
go on i wish i could see his face right
now
no i love this yeah no i disagree i love
this go on
what i would say is
i mean i i disagree and agree i do think
there's a fundamental difference in the
way i think about it
because rational thought doesn't inspire
no
facts don't inspire no but i'll tell you
what does
yeah is conceptually complex
ideas made accessible
with language that people didn't have
access to before they heard you talk
you mean a story no
no i mean sometimes a story
i do think in three acts you can inspire
someone
and whether that three act story is a
pixar movie or that three act story is
a 20-minute ted talk or that three-act
story is a five-minute
story you can inspire someone with a
story i don't think
you can engage people in meaningful
change
without giving them some tools and skill
building
which requires new cognitive ways
of thinking about things i don't think
that all
cognition is rational
dry thought i mean i think storytelling
is a cognitive craft
that has emotional
valence like i'm thinking about going in
and doing some work with pixar when they
got stuck on a film
and it's like ballet the more effortless
it looks
the more really deep analytical
cognitive work goes into it with
storytelling
like i'm a good storyteller because i
understand
the craft of story but who gives a [ __ ]
if i'm not saying something that's
important
so i don't think we disagree i don't
think we do either
i think this is actually not one or it's
one end
right yes i agree and i think that the
story
invites because we started this talking
about
what does it take somebody to join and
then the question is what does it take
for them to stay and do hard work
you know it's like everybody joins the
gym with the vision
in january and then it's done by march
when they realize
this is hard work and they see if gym
memberships go up 12
every year every january
so i think the story does the invitation
and then we want to see that there's
goods otherwise it's just marketing
we want to see that there's honesty and
we want to see that the
leader believes in this it's not just
their get-rich-quick scheme
and i think time you know it's kind of
like relationships i guess when we go on
a first date
everything's amazing because we're
fitting someone into the vision we have
with the partner we want and they check
all the boxes
and then all of the things that are
wrong start to show up
and they're like all right i still like
them but then the beauty and the love
comes later when we realize all the
vulnerability and the hard work i think
that's true
i don't think it's either or i think
it's both but you still need the vision
and the story for the invitation to go
on the second date the third date the
fourth date
you don't start with hard work you don't
start on date ones like let me tell you
all my baggage you'll never get a second
date even though i really wanna know
your baggage and
it's actually gonna make me fall in love
with you
just not yet i'm thinking i'm really
thinking
this is my thinking face so
yeah but stories are not neutral stories
can be
fashioned into weaponry really easily
sure
i'm trying to think about so hold on
hold on i i i have to
so does this mean we can't be vulnerable
on date one
no i disagree yeah that's why i'm
thinking this is why there is such thing
as over
over sharing i've done it
i've done it let me tell you not
effective
no no i think there is an over sharing
but that's not vulnerability they're not
synonymous i would say
well i would say over sharing not good
vulnerability in terms of
you know just being able to manage your
vulnerability on a first date just going
on a first date is vulnerable in itself
it's not like you can choose i do think
that when i was writing braving the
wilderness i studied this a lot i do
think
common enemy intimacy is a very powerful
thing
this kind of counterfeit connection that
we feel when we hate the same people are
the same things and that is the ultimate
falsity of bargain right because the
minute you
start thinking about something and you
disagree you lose what is perceived as
belonging which was actually never
belonging
but i do think that i do
see thought or cognition
affect or emotion and behavior
as a three-legged stool and i don't
see them temporally connected i don't
see that you have to lead with one
and come in with the other for me i see
the way we act the way we feel and the
way we think as inextricably connected
in time and in everything we do
so i'm thinking about your stories i'm
thinking about you specifically
[Music]
when you tell a story
i do feel emotionally
awakened i do feel hooked
and i do feel i feel period hard stop
but i don't think i've ever read i'm
trying to think so it's not hyperbolic
but i
cannot remember an instance of reading a
story that you were telling
or hearing one in person and not being
as cognitively engaged as i was
emotionally engaged
and also behaviorally
questioning so i think there is
for me when we talk about
do you have to have an enemy i think
those
narratives actually
require feeling
to suffocate cognition
the people that do that the best
are people that really don't want you to
think
they just want you to feel which is
highly manipulative which is
highly manipulative right so
i would argue that we're right in the
middle of the book i'm writing right now
and so i'm just picturing all the data
in my mind
i would argue that the fork in the road
goes back to a different question not
even the use of story not even cognition
affect behavior
it goes back to is your intention
self-focused or other focused yeah yeah
selfish yourself does that make sense
yeah i i think intention is a big part
of it i agree with you
what i'm trying to sort of suss out here
the three-legged stool thing
challenges the basis of my original work
which is start with y
which is a three-legged stool but
the argument that i make is has a
starting point
you need all three but you gotta start
with one
and so i agree with a three-legged stool
but
when someone starts with
rational we disengage
when someone comes okay
sorry i do no this is so crazy because
i mean i don't want to argue with you
about your own work i mean argue away i
mean i i just a theory it could be
completely wrong
we are the most simon cynic
organization that you've ever seen we
all have personal why statements
we have an organization why i'm a
freaking chief vision officer like
we are we
and yeah i disagree
with your take on your own work and i'll
tell you why
yeah i think
simon is laughing i wish i could see him
right now
i think this is great i love this stuff
i think the why the genius
of the why yeah is it's the only
first question i've seen in 20 years of
doing organizational work
that captures all three legs of the
stool
but why is an emotional question it
engages the emotional brain
no i think your why work sits on the
throne
of the three-legged stool i do and and
what i think when it's on the stool or
it's a leg of the stool
no it is on the stool it is not a leg of
the school
i think the why says
i want you
to give deep thought
to how you feel i think it's
the yes and so this is okay
stop no no stop stop yes not there so i
just said think and
feel and the same thing so are you
conceding
the game here so the thing that i'm
railing against these days is how binary
we've made our world totally agree
you know right wrong good bad left right
all of these things
and it's none of those things the world
is actually quite gray
and it's usually and not or
and in this particular case i think it's
the same thing which is
are we actually debating if it's
rational or emotional the answer is it's
both
yes and the only question is which is
more effective
to get people to join and stay and do
hard work and the answer is well you
still need both
and even when people are in it and doing
the hard work and they're bought in you
still have to
offer inspiration now and then totally
and like you need it all
and i think where great movements
survive their leaders
is when there is both when there's
there's meat on the bone
and when it's only whether it's
inspiration or fear
you get cult of personality which can go
in both directions
yes great but when that person goes
so does the movement and i think this is
the challenge
that quite frankly let's be honest
personalities like you and me and our
colleagues
have which is some of us have made
careers out of cult of personality
even though we like to think that we
have movements
and when we die it stops all of our
employees will quit and go get other
jobs
and everything just goes you're right
because we didn't take it away from
ourselves it didn't become
rational enough it wasn't something
where a torch could be passed
and great organizations and great
movements light torches that can be
passed
and to your point has both it has the
inspiration and vision
and it has all the rational stuff and
what very often happens we see this in
corporate america most of all
which is there's a visionary leader that
has all of the goods they got the
the inspiration and the rational stuff
and they light the torch and they hand
it to the next person and they die
and they make it all rational and this
is why ceos and cfos who take over from
visionary ceos usually muck it up
because it becomes only about numbers
and only about returns and only about
efficiencies
and the vision the inspiration stuff
the story stuff goes by the wayside and
eventually
it becomes ugly so whether you have
too much of one or too much of the other
it leads to ultimate destruction at the
end of the day and the hard work
is both the hard work is having the
personalities
who can understand both and i'm not even
sure the number of people
who can actually do both which is why we
have partnerships
because somebody tends to lean a little
more vision somebody tends to lean a
little more rational
and you see great partnerships make
great movements and great organizations
i think that's true i agree with
everything you said 100
with the exception oh so close so close
[Laughter]
but i think it's i think we have to
include you're so funny
he's so he's laughing at me y'all with
laughing with i think
we have to include behavior i think it's
got to be thought
yeah emotion and behavior i think that's
because and so we're back to
you completely concurring with the
three-legged stool which is
excellent which is where we well done
well done brene brown
convincing me on my own work swell done
you have to like you don't have to admit
but i'd invite you to consider
this is really worth repeating because i
think it's a great thought
which is the three-legged stool is
emotion it's rational thought and its
behavior
right i don't know i don't usually say
rational plot i usually just say
it's emotion behavior and thinking okay
but yeah feeling thinking and behavior
yeah
and i think the challenge for every
human being
is how to manage all three of those all
the time because it's really hard work
god it's really impossible and there's
this great quote humans don't function
at a rational thinking level we function
from emotion
right and i've heard that it's like we
want to believe that we're thinking
beings but we're actually feeling being
you on occasion think right
and so i do think it's really hard to do
all three
because emotion
can tie up thinking and behavior and put
it in the trunk and ride rough shot over
everything in five seconds especially
when it comes to our self-worth
you know or do we belong are we loved
do people get us which is a perfect
segue
to my next oh god dating no i'm not
not touching that with a 10-foot pole
why is the word vulnerability
or vulnerable so scary to so many people
like i found myself like i've written it
and i said like in leadership you have
to be vulnerable and then i have to
write a sentence saying i know a lot of
you are scared by that word so let me
unpack this a little bit
like why is the word scary there's just
a lot of words that
we have visceral reactions to we have
the same kind of visceral reaction to
the word shame
just the mythology surrounding
vulnerability that it's weakness that
it's over
sharing that you know
you're either the sucker you're the
[ __ ] don't be the sucker you know
that whole line of thinking is so
instilled in us globally we did a
training
in london we had 50 countries of origin
represented
and it was interesting because in the
beginning when we were kind of building
the safe container everyone talked about
their concern about the emotional part
of the training
specifically vulnerability and shame
feeling
not culturally relevant for them and
then at the end of the training
the feedback was the work on
vulnerability and shame
was the most unifying the what we shared
in common the most because
we had 30 languages in the room and
every single person
stood up and gave us a saying in their
own language
that they heard growing up that
completely
vilified vulnerability whether it was
don't get a notion beyond your station
don't get taller than the poppies you
know whatever it was
it was don't put yourself out there
you're going to get hurt and that makes
you look stupid so i think our cultural
training has been
deep and effective so that's why we have
that response to the word
vulnerability has a lot of shared
definition most of it pejorative
right and inaccurate and i think we've
done a pretty good job i mean i think
you're hearing more and more and more i
mean i was talking to my publisher the
other day and they said oh my god we've
got 25 vulnerability business books
coming out
what's scary about that is it can go the
way of authentic
where it gets co-opted by corporate and
then redefined into something that's not
it's really interesting can i tell you a
story that's really funny only if it's
funny
it is funny you'll love it horrible so
i'm giving this talk
and these are newly funded ceos in
silicon valley
and some of the investors brought me in
to talk to them and so
some of them are right in the beginning
of series a funding some of them have
been funded and they're getting serious
b funding
so they're just in different stages but
mostly pretty new ceos
so i'm talking about vulnerability and
i'm talking about what it is and what it
isn't and
afterwards a guy runs up to me and says
oh my god
i'm drinking the kool-aid which is of my
first flag because a
horrible analogy
right and b if you ever leave
a talk of mine and decide not to
critically think about something then
i've not done my job right
and so i said well say whoa say morning
goes no i'm gonna i'm vulnerable i'm
gonna be vulnerable i'm not a vulnerable
person but i'm gonna do it i'm just
gonna look at my investors and my
employees and say look i'm in over my
head we're bleeding money and i don't
know what to do
and he said how do you think it's going
to work and i said
i think it's going to be a [ __ ] show i
think it's not going to work
and this is what's interesting and he
said but that's what you said to do and
i said
did you go on a bio break when i said
that vulnerability minus boundaries is
not vulnerability and you have to
understand
who you're talking to why you're sharing
it why would you share that with people
that have followed you from other great
jobs here
and he said because i'm being vulnerable
and i said it feels like you're being
manipulative
actually and he goes oh and so
i said i do think you need to say those
things
out loud to someone and we should be
very
thoughtful about who you say them to
yeah so i'm not gonna tell you what i
said but i will tell you this
i tell this story a lot with readers and
i always ask people
if you had two-year salary invested in
this guy's company
raise your hand if you're hoping he's
saying that somewhere to someone
and no one puts up their hand but me and
i'm like
what do you think the alternative is if
he doesn't say anything
if he doesn't go to a mentor an advisor
and say look
i'm in over my head i don't know what
i'm doing and we're bleeding money
that's what i call in my work controlled
flight
into terrain yeah you just keep grinding
and doing the exact same thing you've
been doing
over and over and over again until you
crash into the side of a mountain that
you didn't even know was there
yeah yeah like so we hope he says that
to someone
yeah but vulnerability minus boundaries
and an understanding of why you're
sharing is dangerous
that is such a great insight and if you
don't share it with someone
what you'll end up doing it'll lead to
lying hiding and faking every day
yes and that is a terrible strategy for
success
but if he says it to someone that person
will say
go on tell me more how does that feel
what are you gonna do and that process
to your point about starting with
emotion and going into thinking
from feeling to thinking now you get to
go through a process where you get to be
like hold on i could do this then i
could do this okay i got it and then you
go to your team and say okay guys
this is what's going to happen and it's
all built in
and again it has to come out but where
we make the mistake
and this is like kids going on youtube
and telling everybody how they feel it's
a broadcast
i know i know this is a pet peeve of
yours it's not vulnerable
it's broadcast vulnerability minus
boundaries is not vulnerability it can
be over
sharing it can be shock and awe it can
be attention
seeking but it's not true vulnerability
because
what you're looking for usually when you
broadcast
is validation of pain yeah
not connection yeah
and that is the great tragedy which is
if the
impulse is to share it with everybody
put it on youtube go to my team tell my
investors everything
the question is is then where is the
friendship where's the deep meaningful
connection
that you can actually share that in a
vulnerable state
where you're not looking for validation
that's right you're just looking for
safe space
safe hardware right what has happened in
our society over the past 20 30 years
that we seem to have forgotten or be
struggling
to form deep meaningful
connections like i have a friend he's
active duty military he's a warrior
he's a remarkable human being he has
courage that i do not have
and i got off the phone with him
yesterday and we ended our call he said
love you that's how he ended the call
and there's this intense
sense of vulnerability and emotion that
comes with that friendship
that i know that i can tell him anything
because we express
love to each other and my question is
what is it that's happened in our
society brene brown
that we seem to be struggling to form
deep meaningful relationships
or am i wrong no it's a collection
of skill sets that we
are not developing and we're actually
losing
what skill sets degree of grounded
confidence
that we are connected enough to
ourselves
that we are available to be in
connection with others
and grounded confidence i'm really
defining that right now
in dear to lead i defined it as a
combination of three skill sets the
ability to rumble with vulnerability the
ability to actually
deal with uncertainty risk and emotional
exposure curiosity
is a huge driver i would bet a million
dollars that you and your buddy that you
talked to yesterday
are authentically curious about each
other's lives
and then the last one is practice the
confidence
to practice skills
when they have not yet been mastered
and i will tell you i've been thinking a
lot about your research
about the infinite game because the
finite
mindset is so corrosive to understanding
ourselves
it changes the metrics by which
we evaluate ourselves so true and
i didn't understand the level
of corrosiveness of the finite mindset
and its relationship to the inability to
forge deep meaningful connection
until i talk to you in the middle
of analyzing this data does that make
sense yeah
the discovery of those definitions and
sort of
the deep dive i went into that work
profoundly changed my view of myself in
the world
and how i operate within it yeah so
for those who don't know what we're
talking about in the mid 1980s dr james
cars defined these two types of games
finite games and infinite games
a finite game is defined as known
players fixed rules and
agreed upon objective football baseball
there's always a beginning middle and an
end
and if there's a winner there's going to
be a loser
then you have infinite games infinite
games are defined as known and unknown
players which means
new players can join at any time the
rules are changeable which means we can
play however we want
and the objective is to stay in the game
as long as possible and to perpetuate
the game
for the good of the whole we play for
the good of the whole
and there's no such thing as winning an
infinite game you can be ahead or behind
but you can't win
and the problem is is when we apply a
finite mindset when you play to win
in a game that has no finish line you
play with a finite mindset an infinite
game
you destroy trust you destroy
cooperation you destroy innovative
thought
and we've seen this run rampant in
modern business modern politics
even modern relationships you can win an
election but you don't win governance
you know you can win funding but you
don't win business
you can come in first for the finite
time you're in school but you don't win
education
there are finite games within the
infinite game and to be
ignorant of the infinite game of the
context within which all these finite
games exist
you're literally playing for the short
term this cannot last
and what happened when i started to
embrace the concept of the infinite game
as a life strategy not just a business
strategy
is all the things that started to happen
to me good or bad
i started to view as part of a story
just moments rather than
than culminating events so something bad
that happened i went
okay well what am i gonna learn from
this
how will this help me and if something
good happened i'd be like
okay well this two will pass
yeah everything became temporary
so i didn't take success too seriously
and i didn't take pain
for granted and allow it to define me
even the term good or bad
stopped in my vernacular i stopped being
good at something or bad at something
i stopped thinking something was a good
event or a bad event i stopped having
good days and bad days
because those things were too definitive
i had a head days and behind days
i had ahead events or behind events
because they were just moments in time
but friends have recognized it in me i
approach
almost all my relationships differently
to the point of being more
vulnerable more honest less trying to
think
in terms of win or lose is this going to
go the way i want it to go or not
i would say the greatest infinite game
that we're engaged in besides life i
mean if you want to get a little bit
more micro
and the one that dictates the quality
and the depth of the connections we have
is probably self-awareness and
self-love there's a real yearning
to understand who we are to understand
ourselves
to understand where we belong to
understand
our worth to understand our lovability
and our capacity to love and
when we turn that into a
finite game the only metrics that we can
really use
are soulless and empty
and about things we acquire and
external metrics likes and followers
so i think the answer to your question
is very tied up in your own work
which is we are not deeply enough
connected with the infinite love and
energy that we all
are yeah to be able to connect with
other people
i think that's right and you said
something before that we're losing
skills
yes and it reminded me of a story that a
wonderful female entrepreneur that i
know
told me and she said her theory
is that men make better entrepreneurs
than women
this is her theory i have to underscore
that
i'm listening and this is what she said
she said
whether you like it or not traditional
roles still exist so if a boy wants to
go to the prom
he has to ask out the girl you know
traditional roles
and if the girl wants to go to the prom
traditionally she waits to be asked to
go to the prom
and if the guy doesn't ask he doesn't go
and
because of that men being the the social
initiators
traditionally at a very young age
boys learn to muster up courage ask
be humiliated and rejected muster up
courage
ask be humiliated and rejected muster up
courage
ask be humiliated and rejected and as
adults
this translates into muster up courage
try didn't work try again
where women her theory never learn that
skill
and so as entrepreneurs fear
the rejection the humiliation of failure
more
than men and i've seen this happen in
meetings
where a guy you know he's got a business
and he's got some 40 or 50 solution
figured out
and there's a client at the table going
well we need this and he goes oh we can
do that for you we've got that we've got
that
and sell it right there in the room when
i've sat there with women who got like
98
of it figured out i'm like say something
and they're like it's not perfect yet
i'm like just say something like it's
not perfect yet
and you know the statistics about you
know when men look at a job posting and
there's ten requirements
if they have six of them they think
they're qualified right where women
think they need nine or ten to think
that they're qualified
and the question that raises to your
point about losing skill set is
if we're all moving to a swipe dating
scenario that there's forget about men
versus women
like everybody's losing the skill set of
mustering up courage
to ask somebody out be rejected try
again
because we don't have humiliation
anymore in an online dating scenario
i don't even know where to start
unpacking this thing
i'm just the messenger
what you choose to share here's what i
think is interesting about it
that there are skills that we build as
kids that become invaluable as adults
there's no question because of
technology there's an entire generation
of kids that are missing out on
essential skill sets
that are required as adults amongst
which include the skill of how to build
deep meaningful connection
i agree 100 what i would say and i think
it bears digging into the story a little
bit because i do
think that if we look at
shame triggers by masculine and feminine
which i try to use that language more
if we look at masculine shame triggers
the number one
shame trigger for
masculinity is don't be perceived as
weak
so rejection to your point is
really tough when that is your shame
trigger for feminine
and these are culturally bound
expectations right
and so for those seeking feminine norms
the number one
shame trigger is perfection do it all do
it perfectly and make it look effortless
and so i do think
shame the fear of feeling weak
the fear of being imperfect sure let me
just tell you
kids do not pick up the phone i don't
know that my kids have ever picked up
the phone and called a friend they text
i do think the point that we're not
experiencing emotional
conflict emotional hard things emotional
great things
in person has really shifted our skill
set
i see it because i've taught graduate
school for 20 something years
the number of people that can look you
in the eye and give you a firm handshake
and deliver
information that you don't want to hear
is just decreasing by the minute
[Music]
in terms of women and men i don't know
what the data say about who's more
successful in entrepreneurship but what
i do know
is that there's also a lot of
expectations at the table
when the woman speaks up and doesn't
have it perfectly or the person of color
shares an idea
that's not fleshed out completely
there's a lot of generosity toward
the white guy who shares that idea the
number of white guys at the table
who are receiving that idea probably
outnumber the number of women at the
table
and then if you start talking about
people of color indigenous people black
people then you've got a real different
narrative on your hands i remember one
day sitting down with steve
and i told steve that i was really
afraid
that what made us successful in our
careers were
struggles that we went through that our
kids will never have to go through
and we started talking about it my
husband's a pediatrician and he said
we had a lot of trauma growing up we had
a really bad fighting parents
vicious divorces like things he said i
think the key for parenting
and i'll never forget this is make sure
they experience the adversity but they
don't need the trauma that most of us
went through
and i think from a parenting and
educator situation we haven't made the
clear distinction between
adversity really teaching some skills
that we need
and trauma really setting us back does
that make sense so
i think the adversity piece is real that
you're mentioning whether it's asking
people out for a date whether it's not
being asked out on a date whether it's
not getting invited by a group of
friends to go do something
making up stories about what's happening
because we're using social media as our
narrator
and it's happening in the adult world
too and i'll tell you why
let's say i lose my job and i get home
and i'm distraught and i post on
facebook lost my job today
and i get 30 comments from people saying
god so sorry i'll keep my eyes out
you know that does not require anywhere
the amount of vulnerability of me
getting home and picking up the phone
and saying hey simon do you have a
second
yeah what's going on i got laid off
today
that is a much more vulnerable
active connection we call it a bid for
connection that is a bid for connection
it is not a pinata hit with a bat to see
what candy falls
it is calling you and asking you for
your time
and making an intimate bid for
connection and we don't know how to do
that
would your conversation with your
military buddy have been the same
instead of a call he would have texted
and saying everything good dude yeah
everything's good here
take care would have been the same no
what common practices are young people
engaging in now that have become
acculturated
have to change for them to learn the
skills
that they need to be successful adults
and better deal with stress that it
doesn't lead to
trauma people always ask me what the
best parenting advice is that i came
across in the you know 20 years of
research and everyone gets pissed off
when i say it
the best parenting advice i can tell you
is hard as [ __ ] we need to be the adults
we want our children to grow up to be
just like we need to be the leaders that
we wish we had so if we want our kids to
grow up
and be able to have a look you in the
eye hard conversation
they need to see us doing that they need
to see us put our phones down
if my daughter walks in the room or my
son walks in the room and says hey do
you have a minute
if i'm in the middle of something on my
computer i don't know
yeah what's going on and don't look up i
say give me just a second let me finish
what i'm doing
one minute i finish what i'm doing i
close the laptop i turn toward them and
say
what's going on we have to be the adults
and let me tell you
the adults are tapping out of hard
conversations with the same frequency
that the kids are
yeah because they're hard because
they're hard
like you just have to practice you have
to have them you have to [ __ ] them up
you have to redo them you have to i have
to say hey simon
i tried to have a card conversation with
you yesterday and i don't think i did it
very well
i don't like the way i showed up can i
can i have another shot
i really care about you our relationship
is important to me
and i didn't say it the way i wanted to
say it
it goes back to the very first thing you
said is people underestimate the power
of the truth
i hope i'm not romanticizing the past
but it seems these days more and more we
choose easy
you know shared hardship shared struggle
brings us together texas suffers
this catastrophe because of cold weather
and politics don't matter nobody cares
if you're red or blue
nobody cares it's like we're all united
and we have to try and help
keep each other alive and it's a bonding
experience covert is a bonding
experience
it could have been world war ii is a
bonding experience
yeah but that requires leadership that
requires
let's go back to your early point in
order for
covid texas tragedy
to become an opportunity of deep shared
humanity
you have to have leadership that frames
it as that narrative
and uses it to pull us together and not
separate us that's exactly right that's
leadership
and that goes back to what you were
talking about with
churchill or martin luther king or any
of these
who we consider great leaders in our
history which is they use
their words they use their bully pulpits
to take hardship
and make it a shared experience and use
that hardship to bring us together
and not use it as a wedge to drive in
between us one was about advancing
greater good
and the other one was to use it as a
wedge is for personal gain that's why i
go back to this fork in the road
other focused self-focused yeah
other focused leaders servant leaders
infinite mind leaders
daring leaders are other focused
and i know what carr said car said that
the purpose of the infinite gain is to
perpetuate the game
and i hedge it a little bit when i talk
about it
so that people will continue to listen i
say stay in the game as long as possible
and then i say
perpetuate the game but the reality is
to
truly be an infinite player you're
actually playing not for the good of
yourself you're playing for the good of
the game
and we can see this in the best
businesses because the best businesses
will come up with practices and then
advertise and share
what they're doing so that other
businesses may benefit from what they
figured out
that's right so they do these things for
the good of business
they literally share proprietary things
costco will tell you
here's what we're doing you should do
this too because it works
it's not selfish because they recognize
that two companies selling the exact
same product can both be really
successful at the exact same time
so we lose nothing by telling you how to
make your business stronger
that's a true infinite mindset to leave
this world in better shape than we found
it
does it make sense to you why
this framework of infinite versus finite
mindset
came out of a theological treaty
like a theological book it makes sense
yeah i think our lives are finite
but life is infinite and for many
the idea of other worlds or next lives
or past lives
help us make tangible the infinite
nature of the life we're supposed to be
living
and i think that's a good thing yeah
that's beautiful
i think so too i don't care what your
mechanism is right if you want to be
philosophical and james carsey about it
or if you want to be religious about it
whatever
whatever you framework you want to go to
whether it's spiritual or rational
but i think having a framework to
understand the infinite nature of life
and
our contribution to it i think is really
a good thing that this is not the end
this is just just part of the middle
it's interesting because
in my work i had to define spirituality
because i didn't like any of the
definitions of it so i used the data to
craft a definition that just said
that spirituality is really at its core
a belief that we are inextricably
connected to each other
by something greater than us some people
call that god some people call it
fishing
i do believe that part of the infinite
mindset the more i read and understood
it
deeply buried in the foundation of it is
a belief about the inextricable
connection of human beings
yeah you and i think i've even talked
about this my definition of faith which
i guess we could say spirituality
which is knowing that you're on a team
even if you don't know who the other
players are oh
god i mean people just are still
emailing me about that quote that to me
is what faith is what spirituality is
beautiful yeah and it's the same it's
the same definition yeah you know
and i think this is a beautiful way to
sort of sum it all up
which is the tangible things that we see
the tangible world in front of us
is just a tiny tiny fraction of the
world that we actually live in
the unknown the uncertain the intangible
the players that we can't see
are all a part of our lives and all a
part of the game and to operate and go
through the world
knowing that the stuff that i see the
stuff that i experience
is only one or two data points
but the reality is though i am affected
by and i affect the world
and i'm affected by people and i affect
people in ways that i do not know
the way i say hello to the barista am i
dismissive or am i polite
yeah do i ask the server their name
and then address them by name for the
rest of dinner these tiny tiny little
things
have profound impact on ripple through
the lives of others
and we are players in those games it's a
thousand rocks being thrown into
the still water at once i think that's
true i absolutely
do not think that we can disconnect from
each other's stories
i always think to myself too even if
it's a stranger what kind of steward
am i being for this one moment when i'm
in this person's narrative
and it goes right back to truth and
honesty again which is we're quick to
blame
and simultaneously must also understand
where we are to blame they happen at the
same time it's totally fine to say you
did this to me i'm okay with that
but you also have to be able to say and
i did this
to you to you yeah like you can't have
one without the other
and simultaneously people who put too
much on themselves i
i did this and i'm such a bad person i'd
okay
go through the self-flagellation if you
need to and
take a look what the outside world is
contributing as well it's so funny
because
the way blame is defined in the research
is the discharging of psychological pain
and discomfort
that's very clinical yeah and it's very
much in the anger and i do think
blame blame is a part of the finite mind
arsenal
yeah yeah i use a little b by the way a
little b
yeah a little bit little cute with a
curly cue yeah little bee blame
brene brown i adore you i adore you oh i
feel the same
you and i could do like a 15-hour
podcast
like i'm forcing myself to end it right
now but the reality is
i don't really want to end it right now
i was like we could do the infinite game
we can just start talking now
[Laughter]
i really really love you and i can't
wait to talk to you again
i can't wait love you too brother bye
bye
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other